Trascrizione: Andrea Giglio
Revisore: Marco Caresia
Chiudete gli occhi!
Ora vi racconto una storia.
Ricordo molto bene le domeniche mattina,
quando mia mamma entrava in camera
e ci tirava su le tapparelle:
“Dai, forza ragazzi, preparatevi, è tardi!
Lo sapete che per andare in montagna
bisogna partire presto!”
Da piccola non capivo perché mia madre,
ogni domenica, veniva lì e ci tirava
su le tapparelle... per andare dove?
In montagna a fare fatica.
I miei genitori da sempre hanno adottato
questo metodo di educazione:
portarci in montagna e fare fatica,
perché credevano
che fosse il modo più giusto
per educare cinque figli.
Mi ricordo molto bene
queste mattine fredde,
proprio quando con lo zaino, bello pronto,
per affrontare la giornata
uscivo dal furgone blu,
eh sì, un furgone blu,
perché per sette persone
non ci sono altre possibilità
e altre macchine.
Raggiungevamo questi parcheggi
e da lì iniziavamo questa salita
che sapevo benissimo
che sarebbe stata lunga e faticosa.
Ricordo molto bene le mie lamentele,
alla fine ero una bambina
e ad una bambina la fatica non piace
e io non ne comprendevo il motivo;
però mi ricordo quando arrivavo in cima,
in cima queste cime assurde,
ero circondata da 360° di montagne,
queste vette innevate;
alla fine lassù non stavo così male,
ero felice, ero orgogliosa di me stessa
perché ero arrivata fino a lì
con le mie gambe,
una bambina che, passo dopo passo,
ce l’aveva fatta.
Guardavo indietro,
vedevo questo sentiero ripidissimo,
ero veramente molto, molto felice.
Però, il fine settimana successivo,
quando mia mamma mi riproponeva
la stessa cosa,
le lamentele erano sempre quelle,
alla fine, come ho detto prima,
ero una bambina,
volevo fare delle cose normali,
divertirmi come tutti
gli altri miei amici.
Mi ricordo questi lunedì mattina
alle elementari, quando tornavo in classe,
i miei amici mi raccontavano
i loro fine settimana bellissimi:
in piscina, al centro commerciale…
Arrivavano in classe con oggetti nuovi,
come l’astuccio nuovo,
una penna, una maglietta….
Io, quelle cose non ce le avevo
perché il giorno prima
ero andata a sudare,
a fare fatica per raggiungere
una croce di legno.
Tutto ciò non lo capivo.
Crescendo lo capì.
Infatti una bambina
non può capire la fatica,
proprio perché non è una cosa bella
e fare fatica lo si comprende
una volta cresciuti.
Infatti sono ritornata
proprio su quei sentieri
e ne ho capito il valore
e il significato.
La montagna mi stava
mandando un messaggio
però da bambina non lo stavo cogliendo,
perché non mi era chiaro.
Sono nata a Bolzano
il 6 febbraio del 1996,
sono l'unica femmina di tre gemelli
e due fratelli più grandi.
La montagna è sempre stata per noi una
maestra silenziosa, sì,
silenziosa, ma sempre presente.
Una maestra severa, perché appunto,
per affrontarla e arrivare sulle sue cime…
non è facile!
Devi tirarti su le maniche
e iniziare a camminare.
Poi soprattutto la montagna
che ha solo salita...
non c'è nulla di facile.
Tornare su quei sentieri da adulta,
o da adolescente insomma,
mi veniva un po’ da ridere,
perché, ripercorrendo quei sentieri
che avevo fatto, appunto da bambina,
avevo ricordi un po’ vaghi.
Ridevo proprio
perché ne ero più consapevole,
ovviamente avevo più energia.
Ero più grande e soprattutto
avevo più consapevolezza,
conoscevo meglio la montagna.
Perché, alla fine, mi piaceva
e questa fatica che la montagna
mi aveva insegnato mi era servita.
Perché nella vita, alla fine,
bisogna fare fatica
per raggiungere i propri obiettivi,
nessuno ti regala nulla.
Quindi questo messaggio
che mi aveva mandato la montagna
era importante, proprio perché
quello che apprendevo lì,
lo facevo esattamente per affrontare
i limiti e i problemi
della vita quotidiana.
La cima per me è sempre stata
la concretizzazione di tutto quello
che ho fatto per raggiungere
quell'obiettivo.
Una volta lì, arrivati sulla cima,
utilizzando: testa, gambe e cuore,
questi tre elementi, per me,
sono sempre stati fondamentali
per affrontare questa gigantesca montagna.
Quando mio padre se n'è andato
ho ripreso ad andare in montagna
in maniera più consapevole
e soprattutto i miei sentimenti
erano cambiati,
erano sentimenti più forti.
E ogni volta che ero su queste cime
lo sentivo più vicino
e mi sentivo forte
perché ne avevo bisogno,
soprattutto durante gli anni del liceo,
anni non proprio facili.
Mi ricordo che facevo esperienze nuove:
sono andata all'estero, ho fatto viaggi,
ho fatto volontariato,
un sacco di esperienze diverse,
magari dove le montagne non c'erano.
Però questa maestra è
sempre lì nella mia testa,
sempre lì presente ad aspettarmi.
Ogni qualvolta ne avevo bisogno
lei era lì, era lì ad accogliermi.
La solitudine in mezzo a quelle cime
mi faceva stare bene, ero felice.
Potevo starmene da sola,
un po’ lontana da quella quotidianità
che a volte è un po’ pesante.
Lontana dalla città, dalla confusione,
dalla routine.
Questo mondo non mi faceva
tanto stare bene.
Proprio per questo ero sempre
in questa ricerca della solitudine:
io e la natura, in cima a questa montagna,
guardando semplicemente l'orizzonte.
Lì stavo veramente bene,
ero sicura e felice.
La montagna ti insegna
che tutti i problemi che abbiamo in città,
i problemi con i nostri colleghi,
con i nostri amici sono problemi futili,
perché in montagna gli unici problemi
sono pensare a quanta acqua
abbiamo ancora nello zaino,
se ci basterà per arrivare fino in cima
e anche il ritorno, imparare a gestire
il cibo - non è che abbiamo lì
il bar che ci aspetta!
Imparare a fare lo zaino,
imparare a cosa metterci dentro,
perché in montagna c'è freddo,
in montagna c'è caldo e, quindi,
la nostra testa, in qualche modo,
si svuota da quei problemi
che abbiamo e si riempie
di questi problemi primari,
problemi utili,
veramente utili per sopravvivere.
“Chi è questa Petra?”,
vi starete chiedendo…
Ebbene, io sono qui per raccontarvi,
raccontarvi la mia vita.
Amo condividere ciò che faccio,
il mio lavoro è sui social
perché ho sempre amato
questo mondo della condivisione.
È un po’ un controsenso,
perché ho sempre cercato
questa solitudine.
Ma, dall'altra, ho sempre
cercato di condividerla con il mondo.
Perché alla fine, in questo mondo,
viviamo con gli altri,
non viviamo da soli.
Viviamo circondandoci dagli altri
e, soprattutto, le esperienze
che si fanno se non vengono condivise
perdono un po’ di valore.
E, soprattutto, questa montagna
che mi ha fatto veramente tanto del bene,
mi ha dato le carte giuste
per affrontare gli ostacoli,
le perdite, la perdita di un genitore
e molte altre cose…
Cavoli! Perché non dirlo anche agli altri
di fare la stessa cosa!
Andate in montagna, camminate,
cercate questa fatica
che vi farà veramente soltanto del bene.
Sono seguita da centodiecimila persone
e ho una grande responsabilità
e credo di essere cresciuta sui social
perché sono sempre stata me stessa,
ho sempre voluto
condividere la mia passione,
le mie esperienze, i luoghi in cui andavo
e, soprattutto, ho cercato
di trasmettere questa autenticità.
L'autenticità è unica, nessuno può essere
come te, quindi, ben venga, sfruttiamola.
La condivisione, come ho detto prima,
è un tassello fondamentale della mia vita.
Senza questo probabilmente il mio lavoro
non esisterebbe neanche.
Tante aziende, vedendo il lavoro
che ho fatto sui social
in tutti questi anni,
si sono avvicinae a me proponendomi
di lavorare insieme.
È davvero bello perché posso veramente
condividere la mia passione,
cioè la fotografia, amare la montagna
e lavorarci di questo,
perché, alla fine, quello
che ho sempre voluto
è stata la libertà e la montagna
me l’ha insegnata.
E io, con tutta me stessa,
l'ho voluta prendere con le mie mani.
La fotografia, assolutamente
molto importante,
secondo me la fotografia è arte
è ciò che mi permette
di far durare nel tempo
ciò che fotografo, e quindi
l'esperienza che vivo,
e trasmetterla sui social, in questo caso,
e trasmetterlo appunto a chi mi segue.
Tutti voi, in questa sala,
avete delle vite,
delle storie fantastiche
e soprattutto uniche.
Tutti noi abbiamo qualcosa da condividere.
Io, per esempio, ho questa montagna
che mi ha accompagnata nella mia vita.
E tutti voi, sicuramente,
avete delle esperienze diverse dalla mia,
magari voi non siete interessati
alla montagna, oppure siete come me,
appassionati di sport e di fatica.
Però la cosa bella della condivisione
è che ognuno può condividere qualcosa,
anche di piccolo, agli altri.
Perché la mia vita non ha nulla
di più delle vostre.
E quindi ora, oggi vi faccio una domanda:
che cosa vi piacerebbe
condividere con gli altri
di ciò che vi ha fatto del bene?
Perché, secondo me, condividere ciò
che vi ha fatto del bene,
vi farà bene anche a voi stessi.
Quindi, avete delle esperienze
che avete vissuto nella vita
che non volete tenere solo per voi,
ma donare anche agli altri,
proprio perché vi ha fatto stare bene
in una determinata giornata
o vi ha cambiato la vita e quindi…
Perché ve la dovete tenere per voi?
Ditelo anche agli altri,
perché è una cosa che fa bene,
è una cosa positiva per il mondo!
Quindi, sicuramente, anche voiù
avrete qualcosa da raccontare.
Grazie.
[Applausi]